با توتو با توتو باتوباتو
با توتو با توتو
فى الدفء وبين الغيطان  *** غنى صرصور الألحان
با توتو با توتو باتوباتو *** منشرحا بين الألوان
وقفت نملة تنصحه ***  ترجوا يوما أن تنفعه
لا تهدر وقتك صرصور*** فصل الصيف ما أسرعه
خزن جزءا مما تكسب *** يوما دفء الصيف سيذهب
ماذا ستفعل حين تجوع *** لا يعقل أن تحيا تلعب
لا يعقل أن تحيا تلعب
غنى الصرصور ولم يسمع *** لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
إن الحقل به ما يشبع *** لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
هيا تعالوا وأرقصوا *** بالجو المنعش نستمتع
♫ ♫♪♬♩ ♫ ♫♪♬♩  ♫ ♫♪♬♩ ♫ ♫♪♬♩
مرت أيام والنمل *** يجمع من خيرات الحقل
والصرصور هناك يغنى *** لا يكترث ولا يعمل
ذهب الصيف وجاء الشتاء *** لا يوجد بالحقل غذاء
إني جائع فاسمعوا *** يشعر جسمي بالإعياء
يشعر جسمه بالإعياء
يشعر بالبرد الصرصور*** لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
يبحث عن قوت ويدور*** لا لا لا لا لا لا لا لا
يهمس في ندم ويقول *** لو عندي طعام مدخور
با توتو با توتو  با توتو با توتوبا توتو با توتو
ذهب لجحر النمل حزين *** يطلب قوتا كالمسكين
أدخله النمل وأكرمه *** صار لفضل النمل مدين
قال النمل ستبقى معنا *** حذرناك ولم تسمعنا
كى تدخر لوقت الشدة *** ولذلك سوف تساعدنا
ولذلك سوف تساعدنا
با توتو با توتو